[Music]
so you've gotten your dog into fashion
is that correct well it started out
where we were just messing around
because I have a clothing line at Target
and we were putting my dog on some of
the t-shirts and it was selling really
well and and I thought it was hilarious
to see kids you know running around the
street with my dog on their shirt and
then it just kind of spiraled out of
control
yeah he's gone the Hollywood yeah you
didn't react I can't a walk in the park
sick again really salmon at the Ritz
it's bad so what's uh we have some
pictures here of what kind of dog you
have you have a French Bulldog Frank's
milk okay there we go woof
these are different him as different
characters that's the chief okay very
nice what's next that's that's the No
Country for Old Men At unrest Thompson
Johnny Depp yeah yeah very nice Tupac Oh
yeah okay he's good he's good free yes
see no zoo alright you are training for
the X Games next week at the moment I am
all right what's your regimen like what
do you have to do um well we we have
this new system of learning tricks where
there's like a giant inflatable bag it's
like a giant bouncy castle almost and
you do these flips and land in it and
then the goal is to learn the rotation
in your mind and then take it to a jump
that's similar to that and then do the
actual trick but then remove the bouncy
cap yeah exactly
remove it I think next games if you guys
did jumps into bouncy castle yeah I
would love that I could make a call yeah
should make it a little bit more like
mini-golf
put lots of kooky windmills and a giant
floating Dora the explora and you guys
are good I don't know anything to jazz
it up so yeah yeah why not but are you
worried I 7 think I've always wondered
how you do those moves for the first
time well that's this quadruple
corkscrew and then you land and you
think alright how did you train for that
without getting killed this is the
answer yeah it's either like a foam pit
or these inflatable bags it started I
think stuntmen were using them you know
falling off buildings and stuff like
that and then we put them on the snow
the only problem is if the wind picks up
it'll like blow it off the mountain so
it's all tied down and you know it's
really a an amazing thing to learn a
trick like that onto a bag and then take
it to the jump because if I was to try
that trick onto the snow for the first
time and and have it go terribly wrong
that that's kind of your seasons done so
your life could be done yeah yeah
it's now imagining you doing it doing
the flip and in the meantime the wind
blew the bag away all the kids are
already bounced
yeah there are the kids are there blew
it out of here it blew into the Chuck E
Cheese yeah